there's sort of an old-fashioned feel to
everything from the way you order pizza
or the ice cream counter to the dining
room where you have something so unique
happening it really sets it apart from
anywhere else my name is brett valiant
and i play at oregon stop pizza in mesa
arizona a restaurant that serves pizza
and plays the world's largest wurlitzer
organ every night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oregon stock pizza started out in
arizona in 1972
[Music]
the whole idea of pizza and pipes
together started out in the 70s or late
60s and you know at one time there were
150 or so restaurants like this
throughout the country
it's a really good concept for people to
come in and just relax and have a good
time it's totally casual and it's easy
it's pizza
when somebody asks why in oregon you can
walk you know up the street anywhere and
find pianos this is truly a symphony
orchestra and band all rolled into one
and for people to come in and they see
one person sitting up at this giant
console it's something that you can't
find it anywhere
[Applause]
the organ here at oregon stop pizza is
the largest world's organ in the world
and the reason it's the largest is
because they've added lots of sets of
pipes to it over the years so it has 82
individual sets of pipes
the other thing that's really unique
about this instrument is that it has an
incredible number of percussions
everything from tuned percussions like
xylophones and marimbas and
glockenspiels to untuned percussions
drums and tambourines sound effects
pretty much any instrument ever
conceived for an orchestra is present
here
on this wurlitzer
there's nothing else like it in the
world
you can actually feel the power of the
organ just go through your whole body as
they play
the history and preservation of the
restaurant itself as well as
the art form of the theater organ is
really pretty special to me
people they'll say that it's so
old-fashioned in there and that's part
of the charm we are kind of stuck back
in that bygone era i think it's
important to really stick to that
because it is such a lost art form
i don't think we would exist if we
change anything really about this place
it's an experience and it's emotional
i'm very grateful that i get to be a
part
[Applause]
[Music]
you